[Musique]
cher journal bon je lave ou julie les
aperçus des messages sans les ouvrir
pour pas que ce soit marqué lui c'est
vrai j'attends plusieurs jours avant de
répondre pour pouvoir dire que je viens
seulement de voir le message suis désolé
j'étais hyper occupé j'ai pas eu une
minute à moi si tu savais j'ai peur des
trois petits points qui apparaissent et
qui veulent dire que je vais devoir
répondre là maintenant tout de suite
j'ai peur de ne plus avoir d'excusés
inventé parce que plus personne ne me
propose d'aller à cette soirée dubstep
minimale trop cool à seulement 1h45 de
chez moi
si ça c'est pas un bon plan j'ai peur de
mourir et que personne ne se rende
compte parce que mais non mais c'est
normal annales répond jamais aux
téléphones inquiète c'est sûr qu'elle va
bien j'ai peur de mourir chez moi sans
avoir fait le ménage ou pire encore en
pyjama dépareillés ça ce serait terrible
j'ai peur de ne pas avoir effacé
l'historique de mon ordinateur j'ai peur
de ne pas avoir validé les photos
gênantes qu on ressortira à mon
enterrement
je n'ai pas peur de mourir mais j'ai
peur de mourir bêtement un oiseau m'a
foncé dessus l'autre jour mais pas un
aigle royal ou une jolie colombes
non un pigeon alors j'ai rien contre les
pigeons est bon
[Musique]
j'ai vu ma vie défiler devant mes yeux
est entre nous je me suis un petit peu
ennuyé quelqu'un a fait tomber un truc
du quatrième étage qui a atterri sur la
terrasse mais pas une bouteille de
champagne de château latour de 74 nom du
vin premier prix et en plus en cubi à
quelques centimètres près j'y passais
j'ai vécu une expérience de mort
imminente hyper nul
je crois que j'ai peur de recevoir un
darwin awards
ce prix qui récompense les morts les
plus stupides quoique en même temps
quitte à ne recevoir aucun prix dans la
vie autant que j'en reçois 20 pour ma
mort sera toujours ça prix tiens il est
minuit et ben bonne année voilà comme ça
c'est dit
[Musique]